oh thank you
i'm so so sorry for the temperature in
here
the um
sliding glass door shattered
okay
it's actually a really cute story do you
want to tell it babe or should i tell it
i don't like that story babe come on
it's a cute story michael
ran through the sliding glass door
because he thought he heard the ice
cream truck
stop it i mean i like ice cream okay sue
me
oh
no don't i shouldn't say that jokingly
because she will sue me she loves to sue
she loves lawsuits you know honey that
door was extremely clean and it looked
invisible you are so right you are so
right because before i lived here the
glass was always covered in smudges oh
and i moved in and i cleaned it so i
guess that makes me the devil
you are she is she is the devil i'm in
hell
i'm burning help me you shouldn't joke
about that yeah i love cup gangs
alice hates you annie has herpes
if what's your problem my problem is you
smell us ben told you to finish the
website and if you don't do it i swear
to god i'm gonna murder you in your
sleep i know where you live 14th street
right i'm gonna get a melon baller and
scoop your eyes out and eat them and
your congressman uncle's gonna have to
buy you a dog to drag your eyeless face
around
do you understand me
yes
do it
okay
did she get one of these
no thank you
do you even know what this is
it is a fitness orb and it has
completely changed my life
forget everything you thought you knew
about ab workouts
done
this ab workout is specifically designed
to strengthen your core
sorry all right
numerous health benefits
strengthens your back
better performance in sports
more enjoyable sex
you're not having sex
plus improved your reflexes
i would have caught that okay you know
what uh how much is that
it's only 25 bucks wow
um
okay
i'm sorry are you leaving i thought we
had a meeting no we do it's just i think
it's a little chilly in here are you
okay your eyes are glassy oh my god oh
my
she's sick are you sick no yeah she's
sick
that's why i'm wearing this and misting
myself with hand sanitizer
i'm not sick i just have allergies okay
i took a claritin and i threw that up so
i took another one i threw that up and
then i took a third and it stayed down
i'm getting better all right you're
burning up you're burning up what i have
to get out of here i have 2.8 body fat
my body's like a microchip a grain of
sand could destroy it
my body's a microchip
leslie go home no i can't i can't go
home i have to get ready for the chamber
of secrets commerce if this meeting does
not go perfectly then the harvest
festival is gonna be over before it
began i cannot go home okay then who is
your doctor
ann's my doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world
come on
oh girl now i'm hot now it's really hot
okay well that's your fever
leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
i'm going to raise the stakes
you don't
i want you to watch this
and i want you to burn this into your
brains
because this is an image
then i want you people to remember for a
long time to come
whenever you come into the office i want
you to think about this
we don't need to
yes we do what
oh
i did it
thank you
thank you thank you see
i'm still here
we're all still here
oh come on dwight come on man you don't
even know one thing i didn't even say
what they gonna do she asked me the
whole thing and i didn't even do it once
i'm like an elephant okay if i walk into
a room it's like okay he's in there
turn this music down
[Music]
all right who did this
i'm not mad i just want to know who did
it so i can punish them what are you
talking about
uh someone uh forged medical information
and that is a felony okay whoa all right
cause that's a pretty intense accusation
how do you know that they're fake uh
leprosy
flesh eating bacteria
hot dog fingers
government created killer nano-robot
infection
you did this didn't you absolutely not
yes you did no i didn't i know it was
you okay fine you know what i'm gonna
have to interview each and every one of
you
until the perpetrator makes him or
herself known
and until that time
there will be no health care coverage
for anyone
scrawny christians missionaries come to
him and they're like are you john rambo
he's like yeah no like we need you to
take us upriver he's like
it's a war zone up there and they're
like yeah we know we're gonna change
things
and he's like
you burger to do weapons they're like of
course not they do not change anything
go home and then they come back in a
rainstorm this time he says
nope
go home they go home again bottom line
they go upriver
does not go well
i vomited somewhere in this room
i don't remember where though
wait you might want to check that drawer
stop
pooping
you have to get up off the floor now as
far as my friend
nothing like a complete wait for it
wait for it
901 amy santiago was officially late for
the first time ever
all right let's do this who's got
theories uh alarm didn't go up all three
alarms all with battery backup come on
who wants to take this seriously ooh she
was taken in her sleep that's what i'm
talking about super dark boyle but way
more plausible than the sarge's idiotic
alarm clock theory i bet she tucked
herself into bed too tight and got stuck
maybe she fell into another dimension
where she's interesting it's 9 a.m why
is no one working amy santiago is a few
minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why i like to play
i'd say she's in line at the bank
this is fun it is fun but you're all
wrong she clearly slipped through a
subway grade and is having terrible sex
with a mole man
there she is amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself i'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us now
there's a problem in the bank
hot damn
you